[Music]
there's really no difference between
here and home it's just everything's
compacted down to a 14 by 14 room once
you start staffing your look out you're
gonna be working ten days on four days
off late June until usually mid
September it's a pretty quiet existence
this is my 24th season there's a fire
lookout and really it's just you in the
wind and the time just melts away
my name is leif Hagen and we're at Toma
lookout a fire lookout is a structures
that sits on top of a mountain or ridge
top that has a good view of the
surrounding country and the staff are
then is tasked with living there for
extended periods to watch for fire it's
funny because I get a lot of questions
about the standard day you wake up with
the Sun I mean it's hard to sleep in a
room of glass much beyond sunrise first
thing I'll do is make a cup of coffee
and usually I'll have that first cup of
coffee on the front porch sit out there
watch the Sun come up
certainly every morning I go for a walk
I check in at 10:00
[Music]
hey good morning
I have I take the weather every day at
2:00 and check out at 4:15
[Music]
I think the solitary nature when there's
really no fire is going the only thing I
might do is check in on the radio twice
a day that might be the only time I
really talk unless I'm talking to myself
I think what's so tricky sometimes
talking about the lookout experience is
you're not talking to anybody about it
so you more intuitive you more
experience it I think that's why I was
used a term resonance because you just
can feel it and sense it maybe that's
fanciful but it certainly is the way I
feel about it you know you just find
yourself sitting on the porch
watching the world go by for hours on
end it's it's beautiful when you look at
you know lifestyle of a fire lookout it
can be a hard choice at times to you
know I'm missing a wedding tonight over
the course of summer you might miss a
lot of stuff in your life but certainly
every summer I keep coming back because
living on top of the mountain
for days on end it's just such a
beautiful chance at making a life of it
[Music]
so it's the highest you've ever slept at
almost a while when you don't have a
fear of heights it's not really scary
it's like being in the craziest creepy
house that you can possibly imagine
that's Marc's in it he's a professional
rock climber and he's talking about
sleeping in a tent
they're called total Ledger's that's
hanging off the side of a mountain he's
been climbing for over 30 years and his
favorite walls to climb are really
really high alpine big wall climbing is
the pursuit of scaling the biggest
cliffs on planet Earth oh yes they take
a few days to summit so he has to camp
out along the way so I want to know what
does it feel like to sleep in a
portaledge hanging off the side of a
mountain the one thing that's more or
less ever-present in the mountains is
wind it can be pretty violent you can
experience hurricane-force winds there's
also this thing that we call the Bronco
ride wind comes in hits a cliff and it
really has nowhere to go except for up
eventually it hits you and you're ledge
and it can lift the whole thing up so
you can be suspended and then of course
the ledge like slams into the wall
you're just thinking about surviving and
that wasn't the worst of it
the smell in the lattice is not it's not
nice you don't change your clothes you
don't bathe it's wicked scummy but
people love it they continue to climb
and explore through all of this
punishment because there's still that
one question left how does it feel the
way it makes you feel is like a tiny
speck of dust very empowering it really
is just like kind of the most
spectacular spot that you could be on
planet Earth
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
when I go down the slope it takes me
three seconds to get from zero to sixty
miles an hour I honestly can't explain
what it feels like even after 15 years
of doing this floor
my name is Sarah Hendrickson and I'm an
Olympic ski jumper ski jumping is a
sport where I go down a two tract slope
55 miles an hour and when the slope ends
I jump flying about a football field in
length in the air when I'm getting ready
to go the smell is of the fresh air from
the trees and the snow in the area and
the feeling of cold brisk air on my face
when I put my goggles on I know it's
time to go
[Music]
my eyesight when I'm going down the
slope is right in front of the tips of
my skis my skis are bouncing up and down
in the track against the ice it feels
like clatter if you hear it it's like a
lung Bowl the flight takes three seconds
but honestly time slows down and it
feels like an eternity where I get to
enjoy flying as I'm flying I can't hear
anything it's completely silent all
around the wind on my body feels like
when you put your hand out of a car
window going 60 miles an hour moving it
up and down you can feel the lift and
drag it has on your hand
that's like ski jumping but for your
whole body as I'm flying I'm totally
alone I'm in control of all my senses
and all my movements it's the best
feeling in the world
[Music]
when people say they summit for the view
I think they're missing a lot of the
equation of why we do the things we do
the summit honestly is pretty
anticlimactic the movement is for me the
most exciting part
my name is Erik Weihenmayer and I'm the
first blind person to have climbed the
tallest peak in every continent
[Music]
when I was four or five years old I was
diagnosed with this incredibly rare
disease called retinas jeesus it
attacked my retinas and essentially
unravel them
when I finally went blind it was a weird
relief like the worst thing had happened
so there's nothing else to lose
there was a recreational group taking
blind kids rock climbing and that was it
for me it was sort of the full package
of adventure all the things I thought I
wouldn't have as a blind person they
made 14 for this pitch yeah I'm counting
them right now okay when I get on to a
rock face I actually feel like I'm in my
element the things that sighted people
learn to do with their eyes I've learned
to do with my hands
when I'm clipping a bolt to a carabiner
I'm feeling it I'm making sure it's
correctly clipped and if I fall that
that carabiner is gonna hold me
[Music]
I can't look up the rock and see the
holds and plan a big route I can only
see as far as my hands
it's breathtakingly excited sometimes
you hear those cars way down below you
in the floor of the canyon
I love that sound of emptiness a lot of
external stuff sort of disappears and
you're thinking about nothing but that
next hold in front of you
so it's very very meditative very much
kind of like an inner mind sport I like
that I think that's the best pitch could
you feel that space like the exposure
down there yeah I mean especially with
these trucks flying by down there you
kind of echoes through the whole canyon
and you can hear everything yeah what do
you say we top out
yeah let's um it's right up here right
yeah okay
as a blind climber it's really hard and
you just sort of have to embrace that
suffering blindness is just a thing that
happened to me I think like all
adversities we got to use them as a
catalyst to push you in new directions
it's the idea of turning bad things and
the good things and it's something I
think we all could use when I first
started climbing I was so bad I was so
terrible so slow I'd tear my skin up all
the time it was like how the heck are we
gonna go and do Mount Kilimanjaro
three words I don't know those three
words three of the most important words
in my life
all discoveries happen from I don't know
my name is Kyle Maynard and I have an
extremely hard time saying what it is
exactly that I do I've been an athlete
my entire life football to wrestling to
weightlifting and Brazilian jiu-jitsu
and now most recently taking on climbing
some of the highest mountains in the
world
I was born with congenital amputations
it basically means my arms and that the
elbows my legs ended the knees you know
I think some people who they look at me
and maybe even feel sorry for me but
really truthfully my life doesn't look a
whole lot different than yours
you know I type on my computer the same
way you know use my phone just like
anybody else I'm on bumble like anybody
any other single person my age
we got a match my first experience with
climbing really anything of significance
was in a CrossFit competition in 2010
the first workout was yet to do a
thousand-meter row in this rowing
machine in a sprint up Stone Mountain
everybody else did it and maybe 25
minutes it took me an hour and 46
minutes at Arles skiing up on my arms
but I got to the top and I was like wow
this is breathtakingly beautiful and I
told my friend that night I said I want
to climb Mount Kilimanjaro I don't know
if I can I don't know if I can't but I
do know that I want to try to figure it
out I want to go and find a way and and
get up there
there were a ton of challenges with
getting into climbing and the biggest
one was the gear I literally started
with bath towels duct-taped on my arms
to my feet I couldn't go to the store
and buy a typical pair of shoes we had
to come up with a unique solution
now to climb I use a carbon fiber
special custom shoe
I use those to bear crawl up Kilimanjaro
then me and my team we took on climbing
Mount Aconcagua the highest peak in
South America I felt my body was like in
full shutdown mode
and it was brutal at moments but it was
breathtakingly beautiful at the top of
that mountain you know you can almost
kind of make out and see like the
curvature of the earth I mean it was
just a moment I'll never forget the
reasons I climb aren't that different
from other people 95% of it does suck
I'm staring at the dirt I'm not even
able to go and talk to my friends and
see the beautiful views unless I stop
and sit down and look but that 5% that
doesn't suck it's amazing get in a place
that there's no way my wheelchair could
have brought me there that's what I love
I'm not trying to live to be a thousand
like I want to I want to go out there
and have my life means something when
I've gotten down and I've looked at the
mountain and I see what we've achieved
it's like wow maybe that was a really
bad idea that we were there but it was
beautiful
[Music]